hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his treatise
on freedom of choice Anselm of
Canterbury from about chapter 5 onward
discusses how it is that we are able to
abandon as he calls it rectitude of will
rectitude of Wolin tantas that is how
we're able to set it aside reject it how
we're able to take this this thing
that's in our will at the start and that
we have and that we can use and decide
to get rid of it he also considers a lot
of the excuses that people will tend to
make like the devil made me do it or the
force of temptation was simply too
powerful for me or I couldn't not do it
I was compelled in one way or another
and an Psalms position is that these
things are factors but in every single
case when a person who has rectitude of
will chooses to abandon it they are
making a free choice of their own and
they could in fact if they decided to
persevere in willing rectitude of will
for its own sake they could in fact keep
it so he's going to insist
rectitude of will can only be abandoned
by willing to do so so how does that
happen there's really two main sorts of
cases that he considers and the first
one is what we might call a case of two
incompatible options where two goods are
being presented or two evils are being
presented and one didn't choose the
situation that one is placed within but
you do still have some choice within the
situation and this is this is something
that has been you know long discussed by
Anselm's time going all the way back to
Aristotle and the Stoics so it's not
something radically new he talks about a
case of being compelled to lie where
somebody says you either lie or we're
going to do something to you so a lot of
people would say that this is a case of
lying unwillingly and Ansem says well it
depends on how you want to understand
willing and unwilling and it could be
understood as being willing and
unwilling at the same time but we're
we're gonna look at that elsewhere the
key thing here is that a person is being
presented with a choice a you might say
a dilemma the choice is either lie and
live or tell the truth and die and so
you know as he says here we've got two
different wills going on he says maybe
the man can lie against his will and not
against the will we're going to come
back to that as well but he says in
lying
the man wills to desert uprightness for
the sake of his life and in accordance
with this he deserts uprightness not
against his will but willingly he didn't
will the situation that he's placed
within he didn't will to be confronted
with this choice that is so momentous
for him that determines whether he's
going to go this direct
or this direction but the person does
have a choice about whether to maintain
rectitude of will for its own sake by
not lying by telling the truth or to lie
and thereby save their life but to
thereby also abandoned rectitude of will
whether maintained for its own sake or
not they're abandoning rectitude of will
and they thereby lose that as a property
of their will now he also talks about
another common sort of situation that
arises and he calls this issues of
difficulty in Latin you thought you know
users were defect QA and difficult tasks
right so there are many things he says
that we either do or stop doing only
with difficulty and difficulty could be
of all different modalities it could be
that we're tempted to do something
different you know like we today we have
all sorts of opportunities to eat as
much as we want in the developed world
to eat far more than we should and we
may feel the the you know temptation to
go and eat some more of this or you know
go out to a restaurant or order in a
pizza or whatever and we have to resist
and after you've resisted that doesn't
mean that the next moment you're not
going to have to resist as well
same thing with doing things think about
exercising you go to the gym you haven't
been there for quite a while and you're
told that you know you need to do this
and this and this by the trainer and you
get through your first exercise and
you're huffing and puffing and then you
look down the card and you realise you
have 15 more exercises with three sets
of ten each and you're like oh how am I
going to do this right that is a moment
of temptation where you're being
presented with difficulty and after you
do the second exercise you still got a
will to do the third exercise and the
fourth
sighs until you get to the very end of
it and we could multiply all sorts of
examples with this and Ansem says that
that there's a lot of people who will
say I can't do it when what they really
mean is I can't do it without dealing
with this difficulty that I have to face
right I can't do it because it takes so
much out of me R I can't do it because I
get bored or I can't do it because I'm
tempted to do something else instead all
right
likewise things that we can't stop doing
it's not that we actually can't stop
doing them it's that we use that as an
excuse because we can stop it's tough to
stay stopped because there's
difficulties you might think about the
the trouble of breaking and old habit
you know a great example of that is
smoking tobacco it's very addictive you
can't in fact quit but when you quit the
challenge is not to quit the challenge
is to stay quit right now if we're
thinking about this in terms of
rightness of will there are many things
where you know we may encourage
temptations and we we can only stick to
the commitment that we've made with
difficulty so we often say that in cases
like that we can't do it or we can't not
do it or that we do it unwillingly or
against our will or in some respect on
free and some wants to say that that's
really not the case and in Chapter six
he has a really nice formulation of this
he says that this difficulty does not
destroy freedom of will it is able to
beset the will though the will dissent
but it is not able to vanquish the will
unless the will consent so consenting to
it giving in is a matter of one's own
choice and that that is something that
we're responsible for so what happens
when we abandon
of will we can say in every single case
that we do abandon rectitude of will
that we are making some sort of choice
we're making an option between two
things and this has to do with what
we're valuing you know we we should
ideally value rectitude of will maintain
for its own sake most highly and so long
as we do that we maintain it and if we
have it we always can according to an
some continue to maintain it
even if we're placed into situations
like those were being forced to choose
between two different options one of
which requires we abandon the rectitude
of well or when we're placed into
situations of difficulties where we have
to commit perseveringly over and over
and over again and the word that an some
actually uses there you know to
persevere in this and other treatises is
is to make choices over and over and
over again so what happens well there's
there's always going to be something
else that we value or prefer more than
that rectitude of will at least in that
moment in the case of being threatened
lie or will kill you
you value your life more than you value
rectitude of will it could be all sorts
of other things there could be sort of
you know being placed into a situation
where you're another sort of punctual
one where it's something positive that
you want rather than you know not being
deprived of something will give you a
million dollars if you go down the
street and kick this homeless person in
the teeth kicking the homeless person in
the teeth clear violation of rectitude
of will for his own maintain for its own
sake definitely the wrong thing to do
but the million dollars is very
attractive and you're like yeah okay
I'll do that
well then you've chosen a million
dollars over maintaining rectitude of
will in your
you know will for its own sake that is
you've chosen that over being a good
person you've chosen that over
possessing justice and so you value a
prefer something else more and then you
will it more strongly and in doing so
you will something that is incompatible
with the rightness of will maintain for
its own sake and so you abandon it you
let it go is another way of thinking
about it in the issues of difficulty we
have something similar going on you
manage to resist temptation up to this
point and this point and this point and
then you're like oh I can't do it
anymore I have to give it well what you
value then is something else more than
maintaining rightness of will for its
own sake and you exchanged that
rightness of will which now you've lost
and can't get back by your own
activities or willing for whatever it is
that you chose more rest not being
bothered by something choosing the the
pleasure that that's tempting you
whatever it happens to be so an Psalms
bottom line is in every case where a
person does in fact abandon rectitude of
will they do so by their own choice
willingly and now we understand the
mechanics of how this happens either
they're placed into a situation where
they have to choose between two
incompatible things one of which is the
rightness of will and the other is is
something else that they do in fact
value at that moment or it's a matter of
maintaining that commitment to rightness
of will maintain for its own sake
against the force of continual or
long-term temptation but in each case
and some says we in fact do have the
freedom to decide between these
you